hey guys what's up today we're gonna
talk about stock footage again but this
time it's different
we're talking about making stock footage
we're also talking about selling stock
footage first things first what do you
want to shoot what can you shoot what do
people need these are all questions you
need to ask yourself before you actually
go and start shooting anything when we
use stock footage in our pieces usually
it is for the reason of finding a clutch
shot in a piece we're doing right now it
is supposed to be set in New York City
but we do not live in New York or do we
have friends in New York City that have
good cameras so what do we need to do we
need to get stock footage actually on
the videoblocks site we have used tons
of aerial shots and like winter shots of
New York City to actually use in the
piece so what kind of things would you
look for in getting good stock footage
or if you're making it what are the
types of things you want to do so when
it comes to making your own stock
footage and selling it there's a lot of
things you want to consider you want
your stuff in focus you want it to look
good you want to shoot it on it this
best camera as possible there's a lot of
stock footage already out there so when
you are going to make stock footage you
want to make sure you're giving it its
own unique voice its own unique style so
that it stands out from everything else
basically two ways you can kind of
approach it you either go very objective
where you simply try to capture scene
the cam being very smooth less on the
tripod or a dolly or a jib allow whoever
is going to take that footage and allow
them to manipulate it in any way they
want later at the end of the day people
need that flexibility to do whatever
they can with that footage or you can go
very heavily into style and emotion and
giving a shot of very specific feeling
let's say you happen to have a chance to
film a battle recreation like a Civil
War recreation and you want to get a
very intense like visceral like handheld
shot in the middle of that battle
because that handheld look is related to
the exact emotion you're trying to
capture in that shot it's okay to go
that route now you might be worried that
if you go out you get a specific type of
shot that it may not be very usable for
a wide range of people don't worry about
that too much obviously get a variety of
shots but it's much better to have your
shot have a point and make a statement
then just be a vague
generic shot if you're on Rushmore you
could shoot a big shot Rushmore or you
can go let's frame up one of their faces
perfectly and let the rest just be in
the background it's like focusing in and
honing in on a particular thing in the
scene rather than just trying to capture
it all and hope it works for everything
do you by chance live near the Grand
Canyon consider going out and getting
some sweet shots of the Grand Canyon do
you live in a desert consider going out
and getting some sweet shots and desert
animals it's very easy to take these
kind of things in your surroundings for
granted because you see them all the
time but the thing is is that there's
millions of people who aren't there
seeing that stuff all the time
and that is the type of footage that
they happen to need generally when you
say stock footage to somebody start
footage they tend to think of
environmental shots shots of the Eiffel
Tower
shots of Mount Rushmore for example
however try to involve people in your
shots if you want them to be interesting
you know show somebody celebrating
something show somebody being lonely
show somebody being happy we as people
like watching other people and it's a
great way to give your shot a point and
make your shot tell a story mmm
so when it comes to shooting your stock
footage you might be wondering what kind
of camera you should shoot on what kind
of format the footage to be in long
story short you want to be as high
quality as possible generally the value
of your footage is pretty much portion
'el to the quality of it so we're gonna
go out and get shots on your DSLR
uploading the RAW files from DSLR is a
good idea but if you're shooting flat
and you don't have a color profile
included you may want to consider having
a flat version of the file and then a
color graded version of the file with
the best color grade you could possibly
apply so you save people the time and
effort of having to do that themselves
later on and then when you look into
video cameras shooting on a red is great
for stock footage because you not only
get a very high quality file that gives
you raw settings to control you also
have a lot of resolution to work with as
well super smart
well we haven't actually talked about
yet is shooting stock footage for
effects now there's some good tips to
keep in mind here cue the tips cool good
tips so in filming elements for effects
the very first thing you want to keep in
mind is to frame the entire effect in
the shot gosh you're filming fire don't
have it go off the edge of frame if
you're filming an explosion what the
heck just like I don't want that like
nobody wants a cut off explosion in a
shot like what's this what's the point
of that obviously if you're going for
like a close-up of something and
you know gets bigger that's one thing
don't be afraid to tilt your camera
sideways at a 90-degree angle if you're
trying to shoot something going up or
something that's tall just flip it on
its side and capture it as best as you
can usually when you're filming isolate
the background you're in a dark setting
with a black background if it's black
it's 100% transparent if it's white it's
0% transparent and everything the middle
is some sort of blend you want to be
clean you don't be overly noisy so shoot
at a lower ISO and then I'll make it
life easier when it comes to the stage
we have to add the transparency into the
shots because when it comes to VFX stock
footage you want variations of
everything you want almost as many
variations as you can get when it comes
to things that aren't the effects stock
footage try and nail the quality making
my money making it rain money from video
clips you can set up a website and make
us the payment process and get all your
clips up there but chances are you're
probably not to start off with thousands
of clips in your entire video library up
there and it's not going to look very
cool and you only have two clips on your
website there's also a lot of websites
out there that allow you to post your
stock footage on them and sell them on
the Internet
obviously video blocks is one of them
stock would yeah how do you make your
money off these sites usually what you
do is you upload your clip to their
website and each time someone purchase
it they give you a percentage of the
price it was sold for most video sites
offer it's usually actually only about
forty fifty percent of what it sold for
so you have a ten dollar clip you'll
make about five bucks off of it the
reason this happens is because most
websites make their money through just
these individual sales and they need to
take that cut to keep the site up and
running now the difference right here
with the video blocks website though is
that they give you a 100 percent
commission which sounds kind of crazy
but it actually makes sense because
video blocks is more of a
subscription-based website so that's how
they get their revenue allowing people
who upload clips to get hundred percent
of the money of Clips sold kind of cool
or you can run them onto a DVD and hit
the streets it's actually a great series
of articles on the tsukuda website where
they talk about selling stock photos so
if you guys are looking for more
information I'll have a link in the
description below if you want to really
sit down and read from
sessional stock footage seller on what
they do when they sell their stock
footage but if you guys have any
questions hit us up on Twitter or I
guess you can leave a comment below
we'll try to do our best to answer it
yeah